Hello, We are New
Teachers Thriving,
and we are so grateful
to HILT for the support
that they have
provided to us so far.
So my name is Tyler Hester.
I'm the CEO and founder
of New Teachers Thriving,
and I have the
privilege of working
alongside two incredible
colleagues, Dana and Merry.
Quick story, so it was October
of my first year of teaching,
I was having breakfast with
my mom at this literal IHOP
restaurant in
Southern California.
My mom asked me how I
was doing, and I started
crying into my pancakes.
Being a new teacher
was kicking my butt.
And you can see the fact
that I'm not the only one who
experiences this.
If you Google "phases of
a first-year teacher,"
this is a really
common phenomenon.
People step into
survival mode, as you
can see, and disillusionment
in a lot of instances.
This is in the face of the fact
that we have severe teacher
shortages across our country.
There's one statistic
here from California
that 80% of school districts
are reporting shortages.
This is also in the context that
the teachers we have sometimes
quit.
We saw a study that showed
that 22% of teachers
in urban districts don't
return for a second year.
And what that often
looks like is that,
sure, some people are able
to get to rejuvenation,
and reflection,
and anticipation,
but we also have
others who don't really
get much beyond
disillusionment and who
leave at the end of the
year, and still others,
unfortunately, who leave in
the middle of the school year.
This is obviously bad for kids,
and it's really expensive.
A study of all the costs
associated with this
demonstrated it
costs about $21,000
for every teacher who's lost.
So it's a significant problem.
So what do we do about it?
Well, we provide a
research-based supports
to help early career
educators achieve well-being,
and we do it in three ways.
First, is through
in-person training courses.
Second, we're developing
an online course.
And third, I'm writing
a book with the title,
Don't Be Miserable in October.
We're actually
piloting our course
in person with
Boston Public Schools
and the Boston teachers
union this year.
This is a picture from the
end of our first session
a little while back.
So who are our customers?
Well, our customers are
school and district leaders.
And the problems
that we're solving
are, A, student learning
in early career educator
classrooms; second,
teacher retention;
and third, the costs
associated with high turnover.
Our users, though, are
early career teachers.
And the problem we're solving
with them is pretty simple.
It's them not feeling well.
So what are we
encouraged by so far?
A few things.
One is the fact that we're
basing these trainings off
of research that we know
is really sound and solid
about how to achieve well-being
and higher rates of retention.
Second, we've had a lot
of encouraging feedback
from the district leaders
we've spoken with.
And third, as we've seen a lot
of enthusiasm from teachers,
both in terms of feedback
during the sessions,
and also substantially
more applications
for the course than
we anticipated.
So in closing, we just
want to thank HILT
for helping us turn
educator frowns upside down.